I had this idea for so long I'm still  working on it now that I'm bad like  growing up you know and like I said in  in church where we're all told we're you  know Sinners and there were just these  really underlying you know very sad  messages that I very much internalized  and  um  and I'm still like that's one of my deep  core beliefs that I I carry around that  I'm that I'm working with is I you know  I'm bad I didn't have a chance to I  think fully be me like without  trying to fit into everybody's box  around me that what they the idealized  child and not like the real child so I  think now I've  you know loving  all the complexities of myself is such a  challenge I have to allow those messy  parts of myself to  to have some play time